[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia con el asesinato de job en el
mois el 7 de julio de 2021 queda
registrado como el día en el que ocurrió
uno de los mayores atentados políticos
de américa latina y el caribe de modo
que recordaremos otros asesinatos de
presidentes y primeros ministros en
funciones en diversas partes del mundo
uno de los más recordados fue el
asesinato del presidente de los eeuu
john fitzgerald kennedy en dallas texas
el 22 de noviembre de 1963 el atentado
contra kennedy el presidente número 35
de eeuu ocurrió en una caravana de autos
descapotados en la que desfilaba con su
esposa jacqueline kennedy recibió un
disparo en su frente que provino del
arma de un francotirador por este crimen
fue arrestado lee harvey oswald un ex
marine estadounidense quien se presume
fue el tirador pero a quien no se pudo
someter a juicio ya que dos días después
de su detención fue asesinado en
tenencia de la policía el motivo no está
y alrededor del magnicidio hay múltiples
teorías de conspiración
trasladándonos a la región de medio
oriente el magnicidio de dos líderes
políticos estuvo relacionado con el
conflicto que por décadas ha enfrentado
a israelí a los países árabes de una
parte a anuar el sadat fue primer
ministro y luego presidente de egipto
desde 1970 hasta que fue asesinado en
1981 por años sostuvo una serie de
intrigas de guerra con su enemigo israel
en gran medida para recuperar la
península del sinaí el territorio que
ocuparon los israelíes durante la guerra
de los seis días de 1967 en septiembre
de 1978 firmó la paz junto al primer
ministro israelí menájem béguin en los
denominados acuerdos de camp david
auspiciado por el presidente de eeuu
jimmy carter israel devolvió a egipto el
sinaí y a cambio de egipto fue el primer
país árabe en reconocer la existencia de
su estado
el hecho fue condenado por el mundo
árabe tres años después el 6 de octubre
de 1981
anuar el sadat precediendo justamente un
desfile militar en conmemoración de la
recuperación del sinaí fue asesinado por
un grupo de seis soldados egipcios que
lo ametrallaron en lo que se
consideraría un motivo similar
el otro magnicidio relacionado con el
conflicto entre israel y los países
árabes fue el perpetrado en contra del
primer ministro israelí isaac rabín el 4
de noviembre de 1995 a manos de un joven
estudiante extremista judío como séptimo
primer ministro de israel desde su
fundación en 1948
isaac rabín se propuso lograr la paz con
la organización para la liberación de
palestina por entonces encabezada por
yaser arafat similar a los acuerdos de
camp david en 1993 se llevaron a cabo
los acuerdos de oslo
esta vez mediados por el presidente
estadounidense bill clinton
rabín estrechó la mano con arafat en un
hecho histórico que suponía el fin a una
lucha armada de décadas y a seis años de
la primera intifada que había cobrado la
vida de mil 374 palestinos
y cerca de 200 israelíes la paz
conciliaba a israel con palestina por
medio de un reconocimiento mutuo de sus
estados y de un trazado fronterizo de
como un acuerdo pero lo firmado por
rabín y arafat pronto fracasaría en
principio por el magnicidio de ravin el
4 de noviembre de 1995 durante un acto
multitudinario en tel aviv para reforzar
el proceso de paz con los palestinos que
el estudiante judío extremista aprovechó
la multitud y le disparó por la espalda
acabando con la vida del primer ministro
en la región de asia y el pacífico uno
de los magnicidios que mayor causó
conmoción fue el ocurrido en contra de
la primera ministra de india indira
gandhi el 31 de octubre de 1984 hija del
héroe nacional jawaharlal nehrú que
junto con mahatma gandhi lucharon por la
emancipación de india del colonialismo
británico llegó a ser la primera mujer
en tomar las riendas de su país en 1966
y hasta la fecha la única en lograrlo en
su segundo mandato de 1980 a 1984
y reprimió el nacionalismo de los hijos
en la región del punjab al noroeste
indio en límites con pakistán la orden
de represión dejó cientos de civiles
muertos incluyendo al líder xix que
adelantaba el proceso separatista aunque
haber resistido la independencia de los
hijos le ganó popularidad en el resto de
india en 1984 de camino a una entrevista
dos de sus guardaespaldas que
pertenecían a la minoría religiosa le
asestaron 31 impactos de bala
en áfrica el pasado 20 de abril de 2021
fue asesinado en combate militar contra
las facciones rebeldes el presidente de
chad idriss deby luego de haber
gobernado el país desde 1990 sin embargo
uno de los asesinatos de líderes
africanos que más ocupó la prensa
internacional fue el del dictador libio
muamar al gadafi fueron 42 años al poder
kadhafi controversial dictador reprimió
violentamente en 2011 la rebelión de sus
opositores en el marco de las protestas
de la primavera árabe echándose de
enemigo a las fuerzas de la otan
acorralado por el avance militar de la
coalición internacional huyó de trípoli
a sirte donde estuvo sitiado por varias
semanas hasta que fue herido y cayó en
manos de los rebeldes a quienes había
reprimido estos últimos lo ejecutaron el
20 de octubre de 2011 y desde entonces
el país quedó absolutamente fragmentado
en diversos grupos militares en américa
latina' han sido asesinados alrededor de
16 presidentes en funciones entre los
que se destacan venustiano carranza
en méxico anastasio somoza en nicaragua
rafael leónidas trujillo en república
dominicana y por supuesto el más
reciente joven el mois en haití así
concluimos soy andrés suárez jaramillo
gracias por compartir y comentar estas
historias que las encuentran en los
programas de france 24 punto com
[Música]